[Music]  hello hi this is marlo yes  harper yes  come in  the words i have to say it's a beautiful  house  will it just be you staying or  excuse me mrs  no  until you give your love  there's nothing more that we can do  happen from the garden  yeah it was delicious no no  mustn't do that  forbidden fruit oh god sorry i i'm  drinking  oh  [Music]  you're tormented  it feels more like  wanted  yeah  something happened  my husband  went upstairs to our balcony  and let himself go  you must wonder why you drove him to it  why i didn't drive him to it  i think it'd be true  but if you'd given him the chance to  apologize  he'd still be alive  what  a man  followed me out of the woods  he was stalking me what makes you say  that i saw him twice  twice  i don't know if he saw you once  [Music]  i play a game you hide  or see  [Music]  you must feel an awful sense  guilt  stay away from me  what are you  [Music]  [Music]  you